الشعب يريد اسراط الن منذ ثوره 2011
والمصريون لم يتوقفوا تقريبا عن التظاهر
اسقطوا رئيسين اجروا سته انتخابات ولا
يبدو ان الازمه قد
انتهت ولكن ما لم يراه المصريون حتى الان
وطالبوا به باستمرار هو الاقتصاد الافضل
الذي يحسن ظروف حياتهم كلا المرشحين
لانتخابات الرئاسه يؤكدان قدرتهما على فعل
ذلك قائد الجيش السابق عبد الفتاح السيسي
تعهد بانشاء الطرق والمساكن والمطارات
وفرص العمل وانهاء ازمه
الطاقه منافس السيسي الوحيد الزعيم اليسري
حمدين صباحي وعد باستثمار ملايين
الدولارات في اعاده فتح المصانع الحكوميه
وخلق فرص العمل وانشاء مشاريعه السكنيه
وتطوير الرعايه
الصحيه وعود ساميه قدمها المرشحان لكن ايا
منهما لم يقدم حتى الان شرحا لطريقه
تحقيقها الاقتصادي المقيم في القاهره
انجوس بلاير يقول بان اطلاق الوعود في
الحمله الانتخابيه للرئيس المقبل يجب ان
يرتبط باستثمارات من الداخل والخارج من
خلال اعاده هيكله شامله
للاقتصاد لا تسير الامور بهذه السهوله
المشكله تتصاعد وعلي القول بان المشكله
البنيويه في الاقتصاد المصري هائله مشكله
مصر تتضمن ارتفاع اسعار المواد الغذائيه
البطاله بنسبه 14% وميزانيه جاء بعجز يصل
الى حدود الا في من الناتج القومي
الاجمالي الخطوه الحاسمه للانعاش يقول
الاقتصاديون بانها تتمثل بقطع اعانات
الغذاء والوقود التي تستهلك نحو ثلث
الميزانيه وبالنسبه لفقراء مصر تعتبر
الدواء المر الذي يجب ابتلاعه ولتخفيف
الاثار يقول بلير بان القائد المصري
القادم عليه ان ينشئ مشروعات لمساعده
الجماهير مثل النقل العام والمساكن وبهذا
فقط يقول المحللون بان الرئيس المقبل
يمكنه تطوير الاقتصاد ومواجهه مطالب
ملايين المصريين الذين ما زالوا ينتظرون
تحسين ظروفهم
الحياتيه